je suis pas dirigeant syndical mais je
tiens mais je soutiens ceux qui restent
mobilisés mais déjà à lens mais le sens
par l'ansés qui va se discuter désormais
le statut notamment aux dés des
cheminots c'est pas une petite affaire
donc
les salariés de la sncf veulent pas se
faire faire les poches
il ya au lieu de faire un temps d'une
contestation un refus que là encore sur
le statut sur l'avenir de ce métier la
condition lequel les gens vont
travailler ce soit pas une logique grève
je pense que si vous savez la grève
aînés madame quand elle peut prendre la
pose jamais vous ne nous dites que la
grève est nécessaire je dis que si des
organisations syndicales décident de
fermer ces gens là ne joue pas
contrairement à ce que pense madame
bornes ils le font pour de bonnes
raisons pour maintenir rapport de force
parce qu'une nouvelle négociation
commence
voilà et qu'il faut les respecter parce
qu'à la dite en madame donc n'a jamais
fini au-delà de sa vie y perdre du
pouvoir d'achat donc personne joue
personne est dans la posture faut quand
même prendre la mesure des choses vous
avez des gens madame bande a été
conseillère de jospin aux transports
dans ce gouvernement il ya madame par
lee qui lorsqu'elles travaillent les 500
gagner 52 mille euros par mois d'accord
c'est ces gens là qui ont une
responsabilité sur les difficultés de la
sncf pas un seul des cheminots qui
montre du doigt qui nourrissent mis en
grève pour défendre les services publics
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas qu'il mise
en concurrence qui va mettre à bas ce
formidable outil qui était la sncf
donc elle est noble cette greffe n'est
mobilisation des cieux corbières même
alors m aujourd'hui avec ses 7 places
même aujourd'hui il faut passer au
journal qu'il faut pas une trêve au
moment des examens pour permettre au
lycée la lutte c'est quand même ça
rajoute c'est comme ça c'est ce que ces
injures d'indicés la lutte m'arrêter
quoi arrêter
c'est très concret oui c'est très
concret la lutte c'est comme ça il ya
des effets immédiats des syndicats vise
aujourd'hui vers la ville rose et des
questions ce que vous il ya toujours un
argument pour lequel on va toujours vous
montrer quelqu'un qui est gêné par la
laine et il est vrai que la grève gêne
elle grève
elle gêne bien sûr ceux qui ont des
difficultés pour le boulot et puis elle
a aussi des conséquences sur ceux qui
peinent et qui perdent leur serre ça y
est les cheminots y aurait pu dire rien
à fiche de toute manière la manoeuvre du
gouvernement et que nous on n'est pas
concerné
c'est les suivants qui seront sur des
statuts précaires et malgré ça parce
qu'ils sont attachés à une certaine
conception du service public de la
république et du fait que le haut
continue à garder en rail de qualité ils
se sont mobilisés
je les salue je les remercie et
franchement ils ont eu du courage de le
faire
on a peut-être dû reculer mais la sphère
n'est pas fini il ya plein de raisons
notamment des rendez vous électoraux
politique pour peut-être revenir sur
cette affaire